Steven Shea, Filmmaker: I mean
you have the famous quote from
Spaceballs “Evil will always
triumph because good is dumb.”
Film Courage: Why is evil
important in storytelling?
Steven: I think evil is important in storytelling
because it's a real thing I think a lot of people
try to hide that there isn't evil in the world
and I think that's a disservice because you want
to explain both sides of every story to try to
give to try to give the best thought process for
it you can especially as a father now now that
we have a son he's 11 and we're homeschooling
him and so you kind of get to pick and choose
how you explain things to him how you decide
like critical race theory is a big argument right
now and we definitely try to explain both sides
of every story it's like this is what really
or this is what really happened this is the
truth we're not going to candy coat it we're not
going to make up some fairy tale and evil is real
and so you want people to know that such people
that you're educating and so I feel like in movies
it's important too because you want to root for
someone you a lot of people like happy endings I
mean I like happy endings personally my wife likes
tragedies but that's her but you kind of want to
have this this battle of good and evil has been
the tale as old as time back to the very beginning
of existence it's always good versus evil I
mean the Bible is all good versus evil and so
I mean you have the famous quote from Spaceballs
evil will always triumph because good is dumb
which I always think about uh obviously not the
case but everybody wants to be on the winning team
there's a thing that's really popular I think it's
called sports I'm not involved so I'm not aware of
it but people love being on a winning team whether
you're on you follow a football team or you
go to a church that you like or you have a club
that you're into you always want to be on that
on something positive right with like-minded
people and sports is a huge huge element of
that there's always a winner and a loser and
in life everyone kind of loses because we all
come and live and die right there's there's
an end an end game for everyone essentially
death and taxes death and taxes exactly oh my gosh
that's the running joke in our house for adulthood
uh we keep telling our son it's like oh you're
11. you're going to be doing taxes soon it's like
oh no that's the thing he's the most terrified
of his taxes we keep telling him he should be
but I think evil is important because without evil
then there's no nothing to overcome there's no
good guy saving the day there's no hero if there's
nothing to beat it's just a person sitting around
looking for something to do I guess but I mean
that's been in existence of storytelling forever
I would be wondering if there's a if you did a
movie with no antagonist and it would just be a
person existing that wouldn't be a very exciting
movie because nothing would really happen it
doesn't necessarily have to be evil but there's
usually always an antagonist of some kind it might
be taxes it could be the IRS but if it wasn't
then it would just be a person sitting around
I always love when people tell you like oh you
got to do a reality show on me like my life is
so exciting so excited so crazy like you wouldn't
believe it how crazy my life is and it'd be like
okay like so if I shut up your house tomorrow
for two hours for the camera what would happen
they'd be like well I mean I’d be cleaning the
bathroom and I gotta drop my kids off at school
uh I'm like yeah it's not very exciting there's no
story there like you would have to create a story
and the only way to create a story is to create
some kind of genre or a drama create some kind
of drama with some kind of inciting incident with
some kind of conflict and with a conflict there's
something to overcome it doesn't have to be evil
necessarily but evil takes a different term too I
mean I think taxes are evil to an extent though I
appreciate everything they bring us well sure yeah
they're now this is necessary necessary because
they pay for different services that we rely on
yep but there's definitely a lot of evil in our
world and in our country and in our neighborhoods
and I mean you can watch the nightly news
and see how horrific things are and so
that is something that also unifies us people are
scared of evil things and when you can overcome
that or have a hero that overcomes the evil and
saves the day and gives you that happy ending I
mean a lot of people ideally want a happy ending
everyone wants to live happily ever after so
I like giving people something that they
they can enjoy like that you wanna you
wanna have that happy ending I think sure so
a movie about somebody meditating on a bench
where nothing bad happens to them is is incredibly
boring but if we peppered in various things
maybe someone asking them to move over because
they need to sit down on their lunch hour to
use their cell phone to call their bookie
and they're screaming because they just
lost a bunch of money in on a game yep and this
person's trying to become spiritual and detached
well in a movie a movie without an antagonist is
an instructional you can watch a workout video
and a workout video the villain is fat I guess and
that could be your story well I'm gonna watch this
workout video for half an hour and I'm gonna
kill that fat I'm gonna burn that fat so bad
and even then but I mean you can watch a yoga
instructional video and it's a person a person
doing yoga for half an hour there's no villain
there's nothing you're trying to overcome your
ability to feel good or some some
stress you have on your person
or everything and that's an example but I
think if you told someone hey we're gonna
sit down and watch a half an hour yoga video
tonight after work what do you think they're
gonna be like what are you talking about that's
weird weirdo like why would I watch that after
go home have some dinner have grab a beer and
watch a half an hour yoga video that's strange
so I think I think that that's that's
why that that type of stuff doesn't
isn't is included who are your favorite villains
and why I really like complex villains that
a lot of times you have villains that are selfish
or they're they just want something they want more
money they want more land they want to stomp on
whoever they possibly can to get what they want
those villains usually aren't nearly as compelling
I like villains that have more ideals or
want something for a very specific reason
and a lot of times their reasons are good
and makes sense to us that's really good
writing like you want someone to
be able to humanize your villain
to an extent because then it's like then
your hero gets a little bit more complicated
I'm trying to think of a specific
example now that's a good one
I mean of course I like villains that are
charismatic like a Freddy Krueger I think
is a fun villain in our house we're a house
divided my wife's into Jason and I'm into Freddy
and so I always like the fact that that villain is
a is a caricature essentially of a nightmare but
I’m not a I'm not a fan of big government I don't
like that like that's definitely a big villain for
me across the board growing up in a political
family like my father was a lawyer and a judge
and I’ve had more politics than I would ever
care to deal with ever run through my life so
I'm not a fan of that at all and to me movies
are escapism I don't like dramas I don't like
art house films I can't get into stuff that wins
the academy award most the time because I'm just
like I don't want to relive someone else's
pain like that at least in a realistic way
in a slasher movie if somebody gets their
head chopped off with a battle axe I mean
it's a little bit different that's a little
more cartoonish but someone losing their
house to a mortgage and a divorce and having their
whole life get up ended and they're miserable and
I'm like I don't want to watch that like I don't
want to experience that I want escapism I want
something that's colorful and crazy and so I don't
have to worry about the real evils of the world
that exist I don't want to worry about my kid
getting snatched or someone robbing our house and
oh my gosh we just had to get a mailbox because
people kept stealing packages off our porch
it's just like and then you got one of the ring
cameras but the ring camera doesn't see in the
dark so he didn't pick up the people that
come in the dark and it's the whole thing
but and now you're in a database
and now I'm gonna database yeah
exactly because you walked in front of your
own camera it's ridiculous I mean I think I
think the the real villains are are in reality
much more than they are in movies and I like
villains that are more cartoonish because the idea
of a true evil and a real evil in reality is not
one that I enjoy so I think that I like more of
the cartoonish villains and the the big over the
Dr Evils of the world I appreciate more so than
uh then what could be like a real actual villain.
What are your thoughts on evil?